here's to honor among thieves we almost
pulled it off my friends are eatin steak
it's despite what everybody thought -
they're gonna blame us for the whole
thing where the patsies don't forget mmm
we're the bad guys please don't make a
nice
you don't know the half of the we've all
heard the stories of Samson leveling a
temple with a single push
for the Philistine weapon of mass
destruction named Goliath
the next war will be fought with these
metahumans please don't ours or theirs
I want a simple task force it the most
dangerous people on the planet okay
never stand down made up away y'all
Joker's must be crazy this is the deal
you're going somewhere very bad look at
the pretty wife to do something that'll
get skilled you might want to work on
your team motivation thing you heard of
Phil Jackson yeah he's like the gold
standard ok triangle [ __ ]
ah hey the farm okay looky here
oh yeah
I can't wait to show you my toys we're
going to the swirling ring of trash in
the sky they woke in the puck easy-peasy
don't make me shoot you biggest Boston
I've been a trip I'm a bigger problem
when I spread
dog barks too
for my balls I have just begun [ __ ]
wind kids
yes suggesting my vibe but she came back
of my chair
double Gangnam was
hi guys
forgive me for my wrongs I have just
begun Mercy Mercy
y'all Joker's must be crazy
what